Before we start coding
our content provider,
let's make sure the manifest
is set up correctly.
You need to update
the androidmanifest.xml file
within the application tag
to add the content provider
so that Android's content resolver
can see it.
The authority really should match
your package name.
While the name indicates which file
your content provider class is in.
Next, let's code up onCreate.
We'll begin by
creating an instance variable
for our database helper.
In onCreate, we
initialize our instance variable.
We return true,
which is how we tell Android
that the content provider
has been created successfully.
It turns out that we
can repurpose the same test
we did for the database
to test our new content provider.
This will allow you
to both test your content provider code
and see how the content provider calls
replace the SQLIte database calls.
Let's start by using Android Studio
to copy TestDB to test provider.
Let's rename test create DB,
to test delete DB.
So we can start with a clean slate.
We'll just leave the
nContext.deleteDatatbase line in there.
We'll leave the other test the same,
we'll get to it soon.